[Musik]
schmeckt so herbstlich so richtig
wärmend von innen wenn eine Lupe eine
Lupe hat
eine leckersten Brokkoli Suppen die ich
je gegessen habe
[Musik]
hallo ihr Lieben wir machen heute eine
Brokkoli cheddar-suppe Leute was euch
nicht sagen es ist so um Zeit und ist
einfach so lecker aus dass ich gesagt
habe ich muss diese Suppe einmal für
euch kochen so zu allererst wird hier
ein bisschen was klein geschnibbelt ich
schreibe euch ja wie immer alle ganz
genau Mengenangaben unten in die
Videobeschreibung also in die Infobox
viele Fragen in letzter Zeit immer wo
man sie findet ich glaube youtube hat
wieder ein bisschen was umgestellt
einfach unterm Titel einmal was
anklicken und dann öffnet sich die die
Leiste dann steht da alles dran also am
Brokkoli ist es so dass ihr den Strunk
auf jeden Fall bei einer Suppe mit
verwenden könnt dafür einfach nur außen
so ein bisschen was abmachen und hier
dieses ganz ganz harte entfernen in dem
Fall püriere ich die brokkolisuppe nicht
so wie man es vielleicht kennt daher
nehme ich das jetzt für morgen oder
übermorgen wenn ich dann einfach eine
ganz klassische brokkolisuppe mache oder
er kann eine Gemüsesuppe da würde ich
das einfach mit einarbeiten wir brauchen
nur die Röschen und die werden relativ
klein geschnitten und ich mache es immer
so dass ich erst den Brokkoli Schneide
und dann wasche damit einfach das Wasser
auch überall noch rankommt und ich mag
es auch so ein bisschen Essig dazu zu
geben einfach damit es richtig gereinigt
wird weil man weiß halt nie was ich hier
so zwischen verbirgt und da habe ich es
dann lieber ganz sauber
[Musik]
so bei uns vibriert gerade ein bisschen
der Boden weil einfach draußen die
Straße aufgerissen wird aber wir kochen
hier fleißig und fröhlich unsere Cheddar
brokkolisuppe und die kommt auf jeden
Fall auch noch Möhre mit rein gibt
einfach Geschmack und auch noch mal so
ein bisschen Farbe ab und da habe ich
mir gedacht nehme ich mir jetzt einfach
also ich hätte es natürlich erstmal dann
nehme ich mir meine wellenschneider und
mache mir so kleine möhrenwellen ja
nicht cool
[Musik]
wenn ihr die Karotte halbiert aber nicht
ganz durchschneidet dann habt ihr es
einfacher mit dem Schneiden in Wellen
also generell mit dem schneiden weil
dann habt ihr direkt immer zwei
Stückchen auf einmal so Karotten sind
jetzt auch vorbereitet jetzt fehlen nur
noch die Zwiebeln die werde ich auch in
sehr feines Stückchen schneiden und dann
geht's auch schon hier an unseren Topf
[Musik]
so und jetzt nehme ich mir Olivenöl
finde ich einfach vom Geschmack jetzt
besser als eine typische Mehlschwitze
aus Butter eine Mehlschwitze geht auch
mit Öl da wundern sich manche weil es so
gang und gäbe ist dass man Butter und
Mehl als Mehlschwitze nimmt aber es geht
doch mit Öl warum freust du dich so
ja das klappt das klappt immer man macht
es halt nur so selten
Essen und schwitzen ist auch Aroma vom
Schweiß weißt du deswegen so jetzt
schwitze ich erstmal die beziehungsweise
ich dünnste die die die die das nicht
aus dem Konzept gebracht
danke
Leute diese Unterhaltung morgens hier
bei Kikis kitchen und da halten sich
Sarah und Hamza und das sagt der Hamza
du musst dann mal also nicht dass sie
denkt war richtig gut da riecht immer
gut ne du musst Parfüm unter deine
Achseln sprühen weil wenn du dann
Schweiß absolvierst dann riecht es gut
ich habe mich kaputt gelacht so ich gebe
jetzt noch Knoblauch damit dazu bis bald
so ich gebe noch Knoblauch zu den
Zwiebeln und nach ungefähr eineinhalb
bis zwei Minuten kommt auch schon unser
Mehl zum Einsatz also ein bisschen mehr
drüber Steuben und dann einfach gut
verrühren
[Musik]
so das Mehl jetzt auch nur noch eine
Minute reinrühren und ihr werdet merken
dass durch das Mehl später die Suppe
einfach sämiger wird und jetzt lösche
ich auch schon mit Wasser ab ihr könntet
die Gemüsebrühe auch direkt ins Wasser
rühren aber auch so oder so ist es
eigentlich egal also was er mit dazu
erstmal nur so ein bisschen und dann so
dass es sich mit den Zwiebeln gut
verbindet und dann halt immer Purpur das
Wasser dazugeben und irgendwann könnte
halt in größeren Schlitten vorangehen
und dann ja habt ihr einfach schon mal
so eine suppenbasis
[Musik]
das ganze darf jetzt leicht köcheln ich
gebe zu Gemüsebrühe jetzt noch edelsüßes
Paprikapulver wenn es scharf mögt könnt
ihr jetzt auch noch ein bisschen Chili
dazugeben oder Paprika Flocken dieses
türkische Pool bewerte würde jetzt auch
gehen und ich würze gleich auch noch mit
Salz und Pfeffer wobei ich ganz am Ende
auch sowieso noch mal mit Salz
abschmecke und dann kommen wie gesagt
schon das Gemüse dazu also Brokkoli und
Möhren und wir lassen das Ganze jetzt
noch mit ein bisschen sahneköcheln da
könnt ihr euch jetzt aussuchen nehmt ihr
einfach die voll fett Variante oder
macht ihr halb und halb also halb Milch
und halb Sahne oder nehmt jetzt direkt
die 15%ige Kochsahne da sollte komplett
frei
[Musik]
so ich habe jetzt nur noch mal drei
Minuten köcheln lassen damit Brokkoli
und Möhren einfach weich werden aber Sie
sollten halt nicht matschig werden
deswegen reichen 3 Minuten vorkommen
gerade bei der kleinen Größe und jetzt
fehlt noch ein ganz wichtiger
Bestandteil Leute Cheddar Käse Käse
macht alles besser sind wir uns da nicht
alleine
ordentlich was mit dazu das kann man in
der Resthitze einfach vor sich
hinschmelzen und dazu gibt es dann
gleich einfach noch ein schönes Baguette
[Musik]
was hast für Brotstück hier ja Brot zu
Suppe stell Dich abgeholt ja sehr schön
ach das hast du gemacht man merkt
beides richtig original symmetrisch
komplett synchron
wir probieren jetzt unsere Brokkoli
cheddar-suppe
halbkalt ist
[Musik]
so richtig wärmend von innen wenn sie
warm wäre aber sie sind nicht warm
werden
es schmeckt trotzdem sehr gut wenn eine
Lupe
ich weiß auch was passiert
heißt das dass die einfach richtig gut
ist oder also ganz ehrlich durch den
Cheddar Käse ist ein bisschen eingedickt
aber du machst
sehr viel sogar deswegen ich feier das
dass die ebenso sämig ist genau das mag
ich ja
super und so das Käse drinne
gesund oder auf jeden Fall Leute macht
sie unbedingt nach einer leckersten
brokkolisuppe die ich je gegessen habe
ganz anderes man hat halt auch was zu
beißen
also ganz viel Spaß beim Nachmachen und
wenn ihr meinen Kanal noch nicht
abonniert habt holt es spätestens jetzt
nach und ansonsten sehen wir uns dann im
nächsten Rezept tschüss
[Musik]